- My metro card, when it
falls, oh, forget about it.
- I'm buying another one.
- You have no traction.
(fun guitar music)
- I don't even remember a
time I wasn't a nail biter.
- I only bite my nails
when I'm actually bored,
in like a movie or if
I'm sitting at my desk.
- And I'm also a cuticle biter.
- I bite my nails when
I'm bored, watching TV.
- As you get older as
an adult and you have,
like, real anxieties to deal with in real
life it only makes things worse.
- I guess I've tried to stop, it's
more of a like a subconscious thing.
- I know that these are gonna be gross,
but it's kind of like one
of those things where,
like when someone tells
you what is in a hot dog
- Right.
- And the expected reaction is
"I'm never gonna eat a hot dog again!"
It's like, that should be the reaction
to, like, what I'm about to read,
- Right.
- but then, like,
it probably won't stop
me because I'm garbage.
- [Speaker 4] So, apparently nail
biting can give you bad breath.
- I mean, a lot of things
can give you bad breath.
- This is true.
- That is why you
gotta brush your teeth, you gotta
use that mouthwash.
- Floss.
- I use mouthwash two
or three times a day.
- Whatever. Whatever.
- Whatever. I don't care.
- Next, next.
- I don't care.
- [Speaker 2] There is a chance that
the nails you are biting
off may never grow back.
- Hmm.
- I can live with that.
- Are you sure?
- No, I can't, I can't live with that.
- Guess what?
- I mean
- That would solve all my problems.
- And also to like I think
we're almost there already,
- Yeah. Yeah.
- you know, point of no return
- As of now mine have been growing back,
but I'll keep an eye out for if they don't
and maybe that will help me stop.
- [Speaker 2] There are all kinds of germs
crawling under your fingernails,
including Staphylococcus aeureus,
which can lead to a staph infection.
- Oh, that is not good.
- Then think about the
fact that I'm putting
those hands in my mouth
is not the best feeling.
- Yeah, that makes me
reconsider things. Okay.
- Mmm. Nice. Alright.
- That is gross.
That is gross.
- Mmm. Yeah it is gross.
- Oh, see, I almost did
it again, oh my god.
- Not trying to get a staph
infection anytime soon.
- [Speaker 3] You're more
likely to grind your teeth
- [Speaker 4] Which can
result in fracturing,
loosening, or loss of teeth.
- Maybe 'cause you're
just used to biting things
during the day so at night
your subconscious mind
is like, "I'm gonna ruin my entire body."
- This also assumes that
we go to the dentist.
- That is true, that is true.
- I mean, there's a lot of
- You don't know, you don't
- assumptions, yeah.
- know what is going on in here.
- That's a whole other video.
- I know.
- This is pretty scary that
I can actually lose my teeth
- Yeah.
- just because I wanted to
bite my nails.
- I think you need your teeth.
- [Speaker 2] Fingertips
can turn into a "pus bath."
Basically the bacteria,
staphylococcus aeureus,
there is that word again,
can work its way into
small sores and cause
pus build up and those
sores can open up on the fingertips.
- Don't want a nailbiter
serving you food or
putting their fingers anywhere
probably near your orifices.
- The combination of those
- Yeah, that's
- words, pus and bath.
- You're gonna be looking
like you just made it
through the bubonic plague
if you are chewing on
your fingernails, which I feel
like this is pretty drastic.
- I've never experienced that myself, as a
professional nailbiter, however,
that sets me back a little bit.
- I quit on this one.
- You quit? Oh god.
- I quit. That is it.
- Apparently, in some instances,
nailbiting can lead to oral STIs.
Did not know that.
- Ewww.
- What a lame way to get an STI,
biting your nails, jeeze.
Be like, oh, why do you have herpes?
Oh, like, I bite my nails on the toilet.
- That is gross.
- Yeah, that is like, yeah, that is
- But since we're both virgins
- Oh yeah, no, you know.
- It's totally fine.
- Sorry guys. No more love for you because
you might give me STIs
and no one wants that.
- This is gonna making
- I have to reconsider,
- me reconsider, yeah
- yeah, my entire life.
- Hopefully I remember this a
couple months down the road.
- I'm done completely.
- You're done.
- I'm done.
- Never gonna stop.
My immune system is shit
but I'm never gonna stop.
- I don't think I'm
ever gonna stop either.
I think I'm just lost.
- I'm sick all the time.
- Some of these are really disgusting
- Yeah.
- So I have to reconsider
because I'm not trying to have
any of these things happen to me.
And if I see her biting her nails at her
desk I'm gonna call her out on it now.
- Yeah, I'll call him out too.
- Final verdict: still
gonna eat a hot dog,
still gonna bite my nails.
- Let's do a follow-up
in the next couple weeks
- Yeah
- and see if there is any
changes.
- I do apologize to my mom
because she tried so hard.
- I know, same.
- She tried, like,
my mom tried so hard.